à minneapolis les policiers portent des
caméras depuis 2016
cette vidéo a été tournée par l'un des
deux corps de police de la ville le soir
de la mort de john floyd c'est
certainement oui une avenue qu'il faut
explorer comme d'ailleurs une foule
d'autres aspects de la réalité policière
au québec tout comme françois legault la
ministre de la sécurité publique est
ouverte au port de ces caméras
même chose pour le maire de québec
toutes les solutions qui sont
avantageuses pour nous payer pour les
citoyens on est ouvert mais faut que ça
marche des projets pilotes ont été
menées à toronto et montréal de même
qu'à la sûreté du québec et à la grc
après quoi l'idée a été abandonnée
aujourd'hui tous étudient sérieusement
la question à nouveau
mais au pays seule la police de calgary
est équipé de telles caméras je vous
dirais que la première question c'est
une question coût pour les déployer
davantage il faut de l'argent surtout
pour stocker les images mais la
fédération des policiers municipaux du
québec est elle aussi favorable aux
caméras puisque les pôles si ce qu'on
voit souvent une partie de
l'intervention qui explique pas soit les
débuts soit la fin d'intervention est
souvent un manque des éléments qui ont
je suis l'utilisation de la force
et pourquoi le niveau de la force qui
est tout ce qu'est ce que j'en pense pas
aussi simple que sur l'uniforme des
policiers
cet expert invite toutefois à la
prudence en plus du coup les caméras
souvent peuvent être éteintes et les
images captées sont parfois difficiles à
admettre en preuve
la dernière fois que j allais dans un
tribunal il était encore aux modalités
les cubes et qui règne sur un chariot à
roulettes pire
enfin il faut être aussi modeste par
rapport à nos attentes
ça va pas sponsors mirax avant tout d'un
coup tout changé révolutionner le mans
si on veut comme un mini à police elles
n'ont pas permis d'éviter le pire ici
sébastien desrosiers radio canada morin